she makes me so mad sometimes so I'm
gonna do do you wanna do breast milk I
have no party no milk shampoo coffee oh
my god I'm just kidding just kidding
told one of us is this is not funny we
want you to guess which one yeah pick a
number from 1 to 10 are you serious
so do you think is the biggest [ __ ] is
there someone in this room that's
actually pregnant
we're doing that sweater I borrowed it
Ilana I asked you to ask me every single
time to borrow one of my boss be serious
I mean just like the time you took my
hand back to lunch you're not invited
anymore
no are you serious this is my house
[Music]
I look so bad on all of these and one of
them something sexy to me boy why don't
you get something professionally done a
[Music]
lot of come help me that's really good
more my Frederico I wish right
Alley we're ready for you for all three
of you my chicken totally looks like a
vagina
you should Instagram that yes oh my god
it looks like a flaming you notice that
she's been coming home at really weird
hours your way yeah you don't think
she's getting back together with Michael
do you I don't know but I think we need
to follow her like a home from work one
day yes so we are doing this oh my god
there she is what is she doing so she's
getting groceries this is so stupid she
could have been with Michael no she
wasn't with Michael he just wasted two
hours ever like watching her sister day
oh sorry I can't you guys meet Ron
you're her brother we need
[Music]
yeah guys does it look weird that I have
tits you're all sticking out of my boy
[Music]